good morning welcome let me first begin
by thanking the pastor for allowing us
to use this wonderful facility just to
give you a little bit of backdrop we
started this discussion back in January
actually many of this many of us started
this discussion many years ago my good
friend Jimmy Kemp and I we worked on the
Trump transition talking about housing
issues shortly thereafter and January of
this year Michael still released an
op-ed that appeared in the hill as it
relates to housing issues shortly
thereafter a congressman former
congressman ed towns wrote another op-ed
about housing and economic development
issues as we continue to build support
we reached out to reverend al sharpton
and reverend al sharpton was so kind to
send a letter to the president CEO of
Bank of America we began having several
discussions with Bank of America and
Bank of America has been gracious with
their time and with their leadership
team to begin to dialogue with us about
working to engage housing issues across
the nation we decide it may be 30 or 60
days ago to host our first Economic
Forum here in Baltimore so we're excited
to be here today to begin the discussion
about housing policies the 2008 scars
that we encounter are still here today
and I'm going to close and let other
folks begin to talk but I'll close by
saying a favorite verse of mine commit
your work to the Lord and your plans
will succeed and that's what we've done
we've tried to commit our work to the
Lord so our plans will succeed my name
is al Royce sailor sailor assistant Sam
ail o our first name is Elroy il roi
well thank you Elroy as he stated we had
been talking the last several months and
I confirmed a month ago to be here today
to talk about how we must deal with the
decrease in black homeownership and to
come with ways to deal with it we
thought that it was a way to show a
bipartisan way of economic empowerment
that we could work together as Americans
when mr. Kemp who works with Elroy this
came forward I remembered his father who
worked as a Republican across the aisle
with many programs in our urban
community and I remember when President
Barack Obama was in office he actually -
toured this country with Newt Gingrich
who we were diametrically opposed to
politically but went on a five-city tour
to talk about education so I reached out
to our leadership and Larry Young who
led National Action network's chapter
here for a couple of decades and who is
the voice of black radio in this city
the head of an ACP and others but as
importantly the former chair of the
Republican Party Michael Steele because
I wanted people to understand this was
not a partisan effort this was not a
dump anybody effort this was about
empowerment and all of us have an
investment in that little did I know
that mr. Trump was going to on the eve
of this attack the congressman from this
city and not only the congressman but
the people of this city
in the most bigoted and racist way he
attacks everybody I know Donald Trump
he's not mature enough to take criticism
we can't help it he's like a child
somebody say something he reacts he's
thin-skinned and not really mature that
well but he has a particular venom for
blacks and people of color
he doesn't refer to any of his
other opponents or critics as infested
he does not attack their districts he
attacks Nancy Pelosi attacks Chuck
Schumer he attacks other whites but he
never said that their districts of their
states are places that no human being
wants to live the fact of the matter is
Elijah Cummings district is the most
well-educated and middle class aspiring
district of blacks in this country and
he doesn't even know what he's talking
about Elijah Cummings is a respected and
well regarded member of Congress and for
him to be angry at mr. Cummings because
mr. Cummings has the moral standing to
question how migrant children are being
treated at the border is an abomination
to me I am also going to be stepping in
the meeting that the Baptist ministers
conference have and this conference this
conference deals with the fart would be
whole question of that's right Thank You
mr. Trump's agent now as we as we deal
with these questions and we were told
that we were told there's a group of
Trump folks that we know they are there
was a supposed year as we deal with the
100 as we deal with the Baptist
ministers who have tomorrow authority to
deal with migrant workers so we got to
deal with this issue and we're going to
take it on and we're gonna take on all
of those that oppose but I think we
can't lose vision as for his attacks on
me personally Donald Trump and I've
known each other 25 years I've marched
on in with Central Park 5 I've dealt
with him on the birther issue
he had can say what he wants calling me
a troublemaker yes I made trouble for
bigots I made trouble for him with
Central Park I made trouble with him for
birther is and I'm gonna keep making
trouble for bigots as far as me being a
con man if he really thought I was a con
man he'd be nominating me for his
cabinet
[Music]
so he doesn't believe that because if
you remember right after he was elected
he called me president asked me to come
meet with her and he said I'm a roaster
to come and meet with me so he doesn't
believe that but he's playing a race
divisive car we are here to talk about
how we build together and get something
done in that spirit let me bring the
former chair of the Republican National
Committee when Republicans were
Republicans in the spirit of jack kemp
and others Michael Steele hello
everybody
thank you very much Reverend Al it is it
is really great to be back in in this
wonderful city called Baltimore I've got
basically three messages that I'd like
to put on the street today I had the the
extreme honor and pleasure of serving
not just the state but working directly
with the people of the city as its as
lieutenant governor of Maryland during
the Ehrlich Steele administration and
what I found and understood most was how
concerned and engaged the people of this
community and communities like this all
across the state have been so I have
basically three messages in the wake of
as Elroy noted at the beginning in the
wake of what is a continuing housing
crisis a continuing crisis to finance
those who are looking for home to hold
their home that we find the resources
the time and the efforts to partner with
this community as opposed to talking
about this community we find the time
the resources the energy and the effort
to work with this community as opposed
to disparaging this community so the
first message I have is to the president
United States mr. president your
reprehensible comments are like water
off a duck's back when it comes to this
community
it just washes over them it doesn't
stick to them it does not stain them so
my ask to you sir is to join me to join
join Jimmy camp to join others in this
you
allies and appreciate the
hard work and the commitment that they
have made this resort the resources that
they need you can help with the energy
they have you will benefit from and
begin to understand why this is such a
vibrant and important community this is
a place where people raise their
families this is a place where kids go
to school this is the place where
businesses thrive strive struggle find
success just as they do anywhere else
across the state of Maryland across the
United States we are no different we are
not defined by the color of our skin
we're not defined by 400 years of
slavery that is a part of who we are it
is what animates us but it doesn't
define us it doesn't limit us so mr.
president come on down the streets are
ready for you the neighborhoods are
ready for you folks want to talk to you
so just show up put the tweet down
brother and show up that's all you have
to do is not complicated to to the
people of Baltimore you are resilient
you are strong and you are so much
better than anything that anyone ever
has to say negative about you you know
that you don't have to worry about that
so work with us help us help you put out
there what you need make the leadership
accountable to you tell them what is
lacking put in place the leadership you
need to help you get the resources and
do the things to build all of this
district and districts across the city
and the state this is our folks you know
we can sit back and we can complain and
moan about what someone said or what
hasn't been done at some point we have
to get up and walk into that moment to
at some point we have to look at the
black owned businesses in this community
and decide how we help them how we
support them how we grow them at some
point we need to look at our housing
our public school system and ask
ourselves how do we make it better
elected officials only have a limited
bandwidth you broaden and lengthen that
bandwidth when you get engaged when you
get involved so do the people of
Baltimore and the people of this
congressional district this is your
moment to show Baltimore and to show
America your resilience and what you're
made of and what you're prepared to do
as well the third message I have is more
broadly speaking there is still a bubble
that will pop when it comes to our
housing crisis in this country 3 million
people
3 million people lost their homes in
that 2008 crisis 1 million people were
evicted from their homes and yet how
easy is it today to get a loan our
communities still being redlined
that's why partnerships with Bank of
America and other financial institutions
are so important and I applaud and
support their efforts to come to the
table and want to begin to work with
this community to resolve that's what
this was originally about that's why we
were originally called here that's what
we've been planning for 30 days to come
here and have the next step in the
conversation with this community to put
together the action items that we will
need to act on when this moment is over
when we leave this building we got
sidetracked but we should not be
distracted because the work that needs
to be done to improve housing for this
community the work that needs to be done
that will then benefit and flow out in
education in business and health and
other things it matters it is the time
now to do this that's why we were
gathered here that's why we wanted to
have this conversation so I appreciate
the shiloh family for opening up their
heart in their home for us to be here
today to have this conversation folks
don't get distracted by the tweet don't
get blinded by
noise don't get don't get all caught up
in the ratchet it crazy because that you
do that then all of this gets lost I
want to bring up Jimmy Kim Jimmy has
been doing some incredible work and I've
had the pleasure of working with his dad
back in the day and it's even more of a
pleasure down to work with him and what
he's doing in housing and education
community activism awakening and
bringing resources real resources to
real people every day
so Jimmy I'll give you a moment thank
you very much for what you're doing
about it mmm thank you it's a privilege
to be back at new Shiloh Baptist Church
and pastor Carter thank you for hosting
this before all the media attention was
coming as everybody said this was this
was going to happen and part of the
reason why the Jack Kemp Foundation is
involved is because a were based in DC
Baltimore's close we've been here with
events with Joe Jones from the Center
for Urban families who's right across
the street we've been up here with Munir
Behar with Derrick chase in Baltimore we
did a Kemp forum on police community
relations a few years ago at Coppin
State equality of opportunity is what
we're shooting for and when I was
driving here from DC there's not
equality of opportunity in this country
we've got a lot of political division
unbelievably or maybe unfortunately
believably we still have incredible
racial division in this country and it
takes all of us to address it and in the
political dysfunction we find ourselves
whatever you say about President Trump
he is disrupting the way things that
have been happening and so in every
challenge there's an opportunity and I
appreciate this opportunity to have this
attention to focus on issues of housing
and what you know there are many on the
in the political atmosphere who think
that all corporations are bad and evil
well everybody wants a good job
everybody wants there to be real
investment and it takes the community to
help identify where those good
investment opportunities are and I drove
through a bunch of row houses on Monroe
Street half of them are vacant half of
them are occupied those people who have
stuck in there those are the people who
we need to learn from and policymakers
need to hear from and that's a part of
what this effort is and and that's what
the Jack Kemp foundation wants to
highlight and bring to bear and I
appreciate the attention and opportunity
in time to be with all of you and god
Bless America god bless Baltimore and
let's get to work well thank you all
again in Lord works in mysterious ways
we wanted to have a small discussion
with about ten people our friends from
Bank of America our friends from the
academic and thought leadership
community but there was a different plan
of course and you know actually I'm
gonna thank everyone again for coming
out we're gonna go inside and begin our
discussions about housing we're gonna
begin our discussions about working with
Bank of America and working with the
community leaders and the faith-based
faith-based leaders here in Baltimore to
begin to let's make Baltimore great
again how about that
any questions
sure what's your name sir Camille Harris
Camille thank you for that question
we um as I indicated back when President
Trump was elected a group of black
Republicans and white Republicans red
yellow and brown and Democrats and
libertarians we got together and began
to again engage the administration to
talk about how do we bring better
housing to all Americans so this just
did not start 30 days ago it started
many years ago even back to when I
worked with congressman JC Watts working
on the American Community Renewal a new
markets tax credit but more recently to
your question we started with a op-ed
that was published in the hill you all
can probably still pull that up by
Michael Steele it was titled the 2008 of
financial stars of today congressman ed
towns then produced another op-ed then
Reverend Sharpton shortly thereafter
within the last 60 days submitted a
letter to the CEO of Bank of America we
are in the early discussion of early
stages of discussion with Bank of
America we're going to look to do these
sort of roundtable discussions around
the country and smaller venues what we
would like to do is bring together some
actual case studies bring together some
actual solutions and actually get on the
ground and talk to real people look I
served Camille as a staffer in the
United States Senate I served as a staff
from the United States House of
Representatives and I served for
governor and I worked very very closely
with the Bush administration sometimes
in Washington we can sit in our ivory
towers and start writing great policy
with the great heart but it's very
important for us to get out of
Washington and get out of the desks and
actually go to a community so again 30
to 60 days ago we said we're gonna come
right here to Baltimore and begin this
discussion on housing we have not
finalized what that final housing plan
will look like yet for Baltimore but
today was designed to begin the
discussion with the small group to talk
about that engage with Bank of America
in Carson come in the Secretary of
Housing well that's that's a great
question on secretary Carson is a great
friend and a good ally Jimmy and I spend
lots of time with the administration and
with secretary Carson's office I don't
speak for the administration neither
does Jimmy but we are actually in
discussion and I believe there is a HUD
official that scheduled to be here and
planning to be with us here this
afternoon and that was committed several
weeks ago so yes secretary Carson
secretary Carson's office secretaries
Carson's office is definitely looking to
see where he can lend a hand and your
name sir mr. I'm gonna do mr. miyagi
that is that is that is a great
suggestion actually Cara and I were
talking about that the other day in
terms of leaving this meeting here and
potentially looking to create some kind
of splash page or web page where we can
begin to solicit other concepts and
ideals and case studies so yes that was
something we like ambition good morning
I'm Colby little I'm president of the
n-double a-c-p here in Baltimore and we
invite anyone who does have feedback or
who wants to plug in you can visit our
website at n-double-a-cp Baltimore dot
org and enter your name into our into
our website and we can put you on our
mailing list or you can visit our
facebook page at n double acp baltimore
city branches and there you can leave us
a message and give any kind of input and
we'd be glad to pass it on to Reverend
owl and the other partner
in this conversation all right thank you
all very much
we're gonna hope to see president trunk
Reverend Sharpton Michael still when
Jimmy Kemp walking the streets at balls